BENEFIT.
>> DR. RISH AND ALEX, THANK YOU
>> THE ATTEMPT TO RESTRICT WHAT
INFORMATION YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
SEE IS NOW COMING FROM THE
HIGHEST OFFICE IN THE LAND.
>> MY HOPE IS THAT FACEBOOK,
INSTEAD OF TAKING IT PERSONALLY
THAT SOMEHOW I'M SAYING FACEBOOK
IS KILLING PEOPLE, THAT THEY
WOULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE
MISINFORMATION, OUTRAGES
MISINFORMATION ABOUT THE
VACCINE.
>> YOU SHOULDN'T BE BANNED FROM
ONE PLATFORM AND NOT OTHERS.
IF YOU -- FOR PROVIDING
MISINFORMATION OUT THERE.
>> HERE NOW PULITZER PRIZE
WINNING ANDENED INDEPENDENT
JOURNALIST GLEN GREEN SWOLLED.
THE BIGGEST SHOCK ISN'T THAT THE
MODERN LEFT THINKS THEY CAN USE
THE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES AS
THEIR OWN TRUTH SQUAD, BUT THAT
THE MEDIA SEEMS TO BE JUST LIKE
WHISTLING PAST THE GRAVE YARD ON
THIS.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, I MEAN, I THINK I THINK
THE MODEL WAS SET WHEN JUST
WEEKS BEFORE THE ELECTION, THE
SILICON VALLEY GIANTS UNITED TO
BAN REPORTING DONE BY THE NEW
YORK POST ON AUTHENTIC DOCUMENTS
ABOUT THE BIDEN FAMILY, AND THE
MEDIA DIDN'T RAISE ANY CONCERNS.
IN FACT, THEY SUPPORTED THIS AND
THAT SENT A SIGNAL THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, ONCE
THEY'RE IN POWER, COULD USE THAT
MODEL OF SUE PRESSING
INFORMATION FROM THE INTERNET
WITH VERY LITTLE OBJECTION FROM
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO
DEFEND FREE EXPRESSION.
AND THE THING THAT'S SO AMAZING
LAURA IS EVEN IF YOU'RE SOMEBODY
WHO SOMEBODY INCREDIBLY
DISTURBED BY THE FACT THE
GOVERNMENT IS INSTRUCTING SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES WHAT IT SHOULD
AND SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED TO BE
ON THE INTERNET, THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE LEAST COMPETENT TO JUDGE
WHAT IS MISINFORMATION.
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO SPENT A
YEAR SAYING THAT THE THEORY OF A
COVID LAB LEAK IN WUHAN WAS A
CRAZY CONSPIRACY THEORY, AND NOW
THEY SAY IT'S HIGHLY PLAUSIBLE.
WORST, HERE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO FLOODED THE COUNTRY FOR FIVE
YEARS WITH DERANGED CONSPIRACY
THEORIES THAT PUTIN AND THE
RUSSIANS HAD TAKEN CONTROL OF
THE US THROUGH CLAN DES AND THE
BLACK MAIL AND NOW WE SHOULD
TRUST THEM ON WHAT IS TRUE AND
FALSE?
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS.
>> LIKE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
OPERATING A BUREAU OF
MISINFORMATION AS A MULTITUDE OF
ISSUES AS I POINTED OUT ON THE
ANGLE.
AGAIN, WHEN NPR, GLEN, WRITES AN
ARTICLE ABOUT BEN SHAPIRO'S
SITE, THE DAILY WIRE, IN THIS
THING THEY QUOTED JAMIE, THE
DIRECTOR OF THE SOCIAL NETWORKS
AND POLITICAL PSYCHOLOGY LAB AT
WILLIAM AND MARY AND SHE SAID
THEY CAN'T PROVIDE MUCH CONTEXT
IN THE INFORMATION THEY'RE
PROVIDING.
IF YOU STRIP AWAY ENOUGH CONTEXT
ANY PIECE OF TRUTH CAN BECOME A
PIECE OF MISINFORMATION.
GLEN, YOU CAN SEE WHERE THIS IS
GOING.
YEAH.
I MEAN, I THINK, YOU KNOW, THE
REALITY OF WHAT'S GOING ON IS
THAT THESE MEDIA OUTLETS ARE
LOSING THEIR AUDIENCE.
TRUMP WAS KIND OF LIKE A
FOUR-YEAR SUGAR HIGH FOR THEM,
HE SAVED THEIR JOBS.
AND WITH HIM GONE, THEIR
AUDIENCE IS COLLAPSING.
THERE'S DATA SHOWING THE
ATLANTIC, NEW YORK TIMES,
GUARDIAN, HUFFING TON POST, HAVE
ALL LOST BETWEEN A THIRD AND A
HALF OF THEIR AUDIENCE IN THE
LAST YEAR ALONE.
OBVIOUSLY THE OTHER TWO CABLE
NETWORKS COMBINED DON'T GET
ANYWHERE NEAR THE AUDIENCE OF
THIS NETWORK.
AND SO THEY LOOK TO BEN SHAPIRO
AND OTHER RIGHT WING VOICES AND
THEY'RE ANGRY MORE PEOPLE WANT
TO LISTEN TO THEM THAN THE
CORPORATE MEDIA OUTLETS AND SO
THE ONLY OPTION INSTEAD OF
LOOKING IN THE MIRROR AND ASKING
WHY NOBODY WANTS TO LISTEN TO
THEM IS TO SILENCE EVERYBODY SO
THEY MAINTAIN THEIR MONOPOLY
OVER THE DISCOURSE AND EVERYONE
IS CAPTIVE TO LISTEN TO THEM
BECAUSE EVERYONE ELSE HAS BEEN
SILENCED.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT'S ALL
ABOUT
>> LAURA: I WANT TO GET BACK TO
A POINT I HAD MADE A FEW MINUTES
AGO.
HOW DO THE DEMOCRATS, LET'S SAY
IT'S MOSTLY HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
ON THE DEMOCRATS SIDE.
HOW DO THEY THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO HELP THEM?
IT'S LIKE NONE OF THESE
QUESTIONS, WHETHER IT'S ABOUT
KIDS AND MASKS OR ANY OF THESE
QUESTIONS, THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
GO AWAY, RIGHT?
SO NEXT YEAR IN THE MIDTERM, THE
QUESTIONS ARE STILL GOING TO BE
OUT THERE, AND IT'S BETTER TO
RUN THEMSELVES THROUGH THE PACES
OF TOUGH INTERVIEWS.
I MEAN FAIR, FAIR INTERVIEWS,
JUST QUESTIONS.
BUT INSTEAD, WHEN YOU ASK A
QUESTION AND YOU RAISE A POINT,
A DATA POINT, THEN YOU'RE A
VACCINE DENIER.
YOU'RE ANTI SCIENCE.
YOU HAVE TO BE STOPPED.
IT'S DISINFORMATION.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS SINCE I'VE LIVED IN THE
SOVIET UNION AS A STUDENT IN THE
1980s ONCE.
>> IT'S THE SAME MENTALITY.
I THINK IT GOES BACK TO THE 2016
CAMPAIGN WHEN THEY WERE NOT ONLY
SO SURE HILLARY CLINTON WAS
GOING TO DEFEAT DONALD TRUMP BUT
BELIEVED THEY HAD SOME KIND OF
LIKE DEVINE ENTITLEMENT FOR
HILLARY CLINTON TO BECOME
PRESIDENT AND WHEN THEY LOST
FAIR AND SQUARE THEY STARTED
ASKING THEMSELVES WHY DID WE
LOSE?
AND INSTEAD OF LOOKING IN THE
MIRROR, AGAIN, THEY STARTED
BLAMING EVERYBODY EXCEPT
THEMSELVES, AND ESPECIALLY THEY
STARTED BLAMING FACEBOOK, SAYING
YOU'VE ALLOWED ALL THIS
DISINFORMATION, YOU ALLOWED LIES
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
AND THE ONLY OPTION TO SURVIVE
POLITICALLY IS TO CONTROL THE
MEANS OF COMMUNICATION THAT WE
NO LONGER CONTROL, WHICH IS THE
INTERNET.
THAT WAS THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
INTERNET WAS TO LIBERATE US FROM
NOT HAVING TO BE MANIPULATED AND
CONTROLLED BY CENTRALIZED
AUTHORITY AND WHEN THEY SAW THAT
ALLOWING THAT FREEDOM
JEOPARDIZES THEIR POLITICAL
INTEREST, THE ONLY CONCLUSION
THAT THEY REACHED WAS, WE CAN'T
ALLOW THAT ANYMORE.
WE CAN'T ALLOW THIS FREEDOM.
WE NEED TO CONTROL IT.
WE NEED TO SILENCE IT, WE NEED
TO SENSOR IT, AND THROUGH THE
TRUMP YEARS, IT JUST ESCALATED
AND THEY'RE LIKE THIS
AUTHORITARIAN FACTION NOW THAT
GENERALLY BELIEVES THAT
CENSORSHIP IS IN THE P